あった
うん
あ
あっ一尾なぁや最初てがー
走ボケあの
や3位をたくさん撮ろう度もただに気を使ってちょっと野菜とってこうと思ったんです
けど
野菜かな
付けた方がいいと思ったんですよ
なんでちょっとボケのうちのコンビニで売ってたんですけど
おうちで作ろうや採用
プチトマトです
どうすか
おうちで野菜を作ろうペットボトルでプチトマト
アツェ何巨体が来てるらしい来てちょっと水んですけど家でペットボトルで作れる
ちょっとなということであー
本当に史上最強の三日坊主の僕も
ちょっとが本気で
やさいをつくろうと思いますスーパー甲能がの気持ちになってこうやっぱり
人間の根本的たるものはやっぱりこう自分食べるものを作る9自給自足
ねっ
まあそっからねちょっと
毎回たい今度からここらへんにこのトマトがあるんだよ
ペットボトル作れてなんか用意するのは水だけなんですよ
何がすごい
育て方なんですけど日当たりの良い指で育てると約3年半でプチトマトができるとなぁ
なんとかなるそうくってきはそう
うわぁすっ
八かな
なんで結構にゃん
結構がっつり書いてあって
すごいやる気をなくしました一車なんとかなるしたらいい
またセットする
ヘッドボトルやグラスにお水を入れて
th
ペットボトルに水を入れましょうって書いたよウーロン茶で一緒のうろん茶のほうが
その月が迫ったか
ここがちゃんと費かけないとかれるということです
たね入れてアップさんのでお水はそっとあげると
たねー
じゃあ2弦2弦にしておきます
この2粒アップサンド
こんなもんか
そしたらこれでいいと思いますで水を23滴やるとポンッ
manage 蜜なればいい何やらなくていいのかな水やらなくていいのうやらなくて
いいのかわかんないのかな
大丈夫スターン1週間後に資料をあげなきゃいけないということなんで解体さがて
なかったら
原因は間違いなく
大津はを使ったことですぜひみんなでこの
僕のトマトよっ栗
今もってあげましょう
じゃああああああああっ
ni